this is the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hashim Aziz and today
I'm in Waterloo I'm in the very core
offices of salt and I'm with Emma Loman
who is the business development manager
for Seoul uncovering the UK and the US
hello recruitment world hello
recruitment this is the center of the
recruitment no Emma thank you so much
for joining me
I know we've we've sort of gone back and
forth for a little bit ever mean to get
to get this bit - yeah got it bits in
we're here we're ready to go I'm excited
to uncover the Emma Loman so we're
always like to start as I was telling
you before hand how the hell you get
into recruitment well you know like all
recruiters I think you know I came out
the womb and I was like I want to be a
recruiter mom do you know you're like
the fourth person that's done that no so
I I'm not gonna big myself out boom I'm
quite intelligent okay and you know um
did really well at school but I didn't
know what I wanted to do didn't
necessary I bet everyone does you know
everyone said this haven't they no I
didn't go to uni okay no sorry before
you smart I am but I didn't know I got
good grades and basically just thought
you know I need money yeah so I became a
debt collector okay so what you wanted
to take other people's money I thought
how can I get my know so it was
literally the worst room in the world it
was a cool Center yeah debt collection
you'd sit there with a headset have like
things popping up and you'd have to
basically ask people to pay debts that
they've been avoiding for like six
months I'm sure there's no those cause
like was it like yeah it's like lets you
force them to pay on the phone you have
to you know help you have to suggest
that they pay but to be honest it was I
think I did it for about two years from
when I was 17 to 19 yeah
and it was like the best in a way like
recruitment training I could have done
because not that they were trained him
anything about recruitment but it was
basically me selling you know trying to
get people to do something they didn't
want to do which not we do that
recruitment but you know it was great
grounding and then from that I decided I
don't want to be a debt collector my
whole life what should I do
I got a job at a really small exec
search firm who worked in software sales
okay so did you know about recruitment
at this point I was your recruitment I
think coming out of like college and not
having a degree or anything like that I
know I wanted a career in something but
I didn't know what I wanted that career
to be and just so you know your
recruitment looks quite good
and but I didn't actually get a job as a
recruiter so it was a really small
company and I basically was gonna be
doing admin there was doing no I knew I
was doing so I went in and the reason is
their resources it was a really really
small company like and talking for
people yeah I joined the company is yeah
so they only hire people with degrees
and I don't have degree supporting them
online I was doing like the research
inside actually speaking to people like
yeah exactly
and then people kept coming in to this
is you know meeting candidates face to
face they'd come into office we'd sit
down we didn't view them and I've been
at hide you want a cup of coffee food
you want a cup of tea and then about
after a couple of months of doing that
the director said actually you know even
they don't have a degree you know you're
not a [ __ ] why don't you actually get
on the phone and I was okay so I was
there for two years
okay and I was still basically
resourcing so it was a candidate focus
well yeah so they would pick up jobs in
software sales and this was like super
old-school this is like before LinkedIn
recruiter really we used to have to call
oh dear 28 okay I've had a lot of Botox
[Laughter]
okay just enough okay go say we didn't
fall in tomorrow so what how would they
put in job just like cold calls so they
had a they were like quite old they've
been doing it for like 20 years
they had a really good Network they were
working with like I be MHP like software
companies welcome senior level hires and
it was really like traditional market
mapping so I'd have to go on LinkedIn
look at everyone who you know they're
competitive yeah spreadsheet call them
at work call them at their desk all that
kind of stuff and it was really really
hard like we used to have to stand up in
front of the directors I'm sure they're
not listening but if they're I'm sure
they won't mind it was great guys it was
amazing learning curve for me yeah but
it was really tough because you know we
had to know everything about these big
companies and also they wouldn't settle
for like you know you can't go on a job
board they wanted the best of the best
yeah yeah sorry you have to stand up and
do what like just way cooler than that
no we had to stand up and recite like if
we were gonna pitch a company we'd have
to stand up and talk about the share
prize the Grove people and I used to go
and cry in the toilet then I've come
back and do it so wait wait just just
quickly on that point it was just out of
interest like what was the sales pitch
if you get on in focusing on so say
we've got so say we caught so IBM just
have a portal where you could basically
type in any employee it would come up
with their work mobile number Wow so how
do you think they have that anymore but
so you say I'm trying to get hold of
someone IBM as a sales guy and I'm
recruiting for X company where were you
had access to a portal it's a piece of
public thing it was their phone evidence
and then highbaugh was on that yeah
because it was their work it was their
work my bowl all right that was the
thing okay
probably soliciting now okay it's not
useful recruitment it's used for like
its largest embassy yes okay cool sad to
call up a recruiter
nope that's a cool yeah I'd have to be
at high mr. John Smith how you it's Emma
Loman calling from Orem oh good yeah and
I'd have to be like look if you've got
five minutes
I know you're probably not looking for a
new job but I've been specifically told
to approach you about this role
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla and they
don't you know usually tell you to get
lost or they go okay fine who is it and
because you're in that situation you're
talking to people that earn a lot of
money you'd have to go well but this
company they do this this this this this
they go you know yeah they basically
draw you so you'd have to know all this
stuff now yes but what just out of
interest okay definitely sounds that
makes sense yeah that makes sense but
all I was just interested in because I'm
thinking okay it would just be
interested to actually understand like
what these really experienced recruiters
yeah decided to include in that sales
pitch to go I mean ya know so typically
it would be like their growth over the
last sort of three years in terms of
their finances so they've grown by 104
percent specifically what the product
did whether they were a market leader if
they'd been in like like Gartner's Magic
Quadrant and if you know those guys
they're like an analyst report okay if
they featuring any of that yeah you know
you can like Google stuff about
companies it comes up with whatever so
anything like that sort of highlights
about them to try and make them say that
actually have a conversation with you
okay cool fair enough so just interested
that so how do you do that for two years
like see a lot on the phone yeah yeah
would you winning clients at this point
no I never did any I never want any
clients really okay today they brung on
the jobs yeah say thirty people on a
list that would get that dope could get
that job and then we would have to speed
to every single person on that list and
we couldn't rest until every single
person admits what was the most corn
injection you got just some people
weren't looking at you know in sales if
they're really really doing well and
they're hitting their number and over
again and they're gonna earn like five
hundred grand
they're not gonna leave but those are
the people that you want so it's kind of
like some people could be swayed maybe
they're gonna get you know whatever
increase on their salary but that's a
lot of the time sometimes people are
just like super happy you can't be happy
math so that was your grant that's what
that's like the reason why I said that's
mad it's because so what so you'd call
that as light headhunting I don't know
if I'd even call that headhunting I feel
like if you look at exact shirt firms or
that's what they do they probably do it
in a more well yeah I guess I think a
lot of companies will say they do exact
search but they just kind of fluff it up
we'll doing the same thing same people
you know yeah no I just again being on
this line I never did that what do you
create insurance but like I mean I we
never I'm pretty sure it and knowing
than the office well maybe one person
every now and again would cool someone
at their desk see I don't agree I
wouldn't agree with it now really I'm
totally I think now people have changed
the way we interact with people change
so I definitely wouldn't do it now but
then there was no option like you
couldn't add people on LinkedIn you had
to enter their email address and that
kind of you thought that I'd be
important
ok ok no ok so that's really interesting
then so how did you get on doing that
then like did you bits I do well no so
it was just on basically filling their
roles I didn't have a revenues mission
yeah got like 200 quid what per
placement probably I'm so I was like 90
I know I must have been about 20 20 no I
must have been how I've been 21 at this
point yeah so I can't really remember
but you but it was like just more of
like a fit probably about 200 pounds I
think a place placement and it was
actually the hardest recruitment I think
I've ever done which is the irony of him
once she got him on the hook like what's
your involvement after that just out of
interest was you then managing
everything again for the interviews and
all that qualifying it was a really
small company it was literally four
people so it's not as if we had people
to hand things like forever but I you
know I was really really lucky to join
that company because I've got you know
trained from two directors that did that
and they had nothing else with their
spare time except for train me and this
other guy so you know yeah it was really
difficult but also I think it taught me
a lot of really good like grounding
I think when you join a big company you
know no matter how hard companies try
obviously we can't donate like give time
to every single person and get them to
be the way we kind of want it to I think
that's that's always a car every day
babes okay on that point them before we
move on to things whatever sort of like
you said that it was a really good
ground and was there anything else that
really helped you with like if you look
back now that like some really key
you're really glad that that happens so
you obviously clearly got some from day
one you've got some real sort of
experiences getting rejection so you
know for me it was very very very
process driven okay she's really
organized so I'm very very badly
organized so it was very good for me to
do that also I think you know the
attitude of not giving up in terms of
the fact that now we have way so like so
many more candidates so much more to
choose from but realistically we've
still got to do a good job for clients
and they still want those top-tier
people so I think now it's quite easy to
go we'll have sent them a message
they're not coming back to me they're
not interested where is I'm definitely
more about okay you may have sent them a
message but what else have you done have
you actually spoken to them can you get
him to go to a coffee with this guy like
that was the one thing it taught me it
was I such a cheesy saying absolutely
hate it but my old directiy to say we're
not making marriages we're just making
the first day and I like God but it's
kind of true in a way like you're not
forcing people to go and take the job
you just want to get them to go and have
that initial conversation I think if you
do that people get invested so I think
that that was a good processes okay that
that's interested in and then you just
touch them it there which was which was
my second point as you said crying a lot
of the days yep difficult yep why didn't
you quit I didn't quit because I'm not a
quitter how'd you get for it I think I
knew that it was really good learning
like recruitment you know for me
personally and this is absolutely no
disrespect I don't know come across in a
bad way
but I didn't want to go to one of like
the bigger agencies I could read or
whatever I thought to myself I want to
do stuff with bigger fees and I want to
do stuff that's more like in a
headhunting sort of approach and so I
knew it I knew it was gonna be really
horrible and you know no one wants to
make those coke what made you want was
why I don't know I just thought I just
thought in my head I think I'd seen
maybe a like film about headhunter or
sowing in New York and I was like oh my
god that's gonna be me so I think I just
want I knew that would actually get me
really really good training so even
though yeah it was really difficult
you had the sort of self-awareness or
perspective to be like well actually
like this is gonna help me become better
exactly and I know and at the time as
well they were gonna grow the company
well I suppose because he had nowhere to
hide in looking back on it and you know
both the directors were absolutely like
I said they were amazing but looking
back on it it probably was I definitely
felt out of my depth a lot of the time I
don't think I really found a bird you'd
like some kind of like Firefly I was
like you've just got to kind of crack on
with this and get it done oh my god so
okay so it's were there for two years
that's really interesting and then
obviously joined soul who of it so how
big were they when I joined so I got
approached by rhetoric and he sent me a
message and at this point I'd been
crying in the toilet you know more than
regularly so I thought you know maybe
they go yeah also I live in Surrey so
this recruitment agency was in Surrey
not in London and I was like bright
lights big city you know let's move you
know so I said yeah okay
you know went to the interview and when
I interviewed it so I think there was
like 35 people okay so gosh I think
we've got 250 people now yes ma'am so we
just acquired another business like two
weeks ago
in the press nice yeah so it was a
completely different company I remember
I came in on my first day and they were
like oh you know there was jobs and you
know I had like James will she's the
regional director New York was I is like
one of these best managers I've ever had
he was really supportive he was oh yeah
like doing the looking details to the
job board and I was like what what's the
job pause yeah I just didn't know what
job was they know what boolean search
what made you join so I have interest in
got interviewed by Elia who was really
you know had such an amazing vision was
really passionate about the company yeah
it was just had a really good culture
like we've been in this office since I
joined and I think it's just one of
those places you just walk through the
door and it's just got such a good
energy and vibe line like that that's
like no BS like yeah like I've been
talking to quite a lot of love citizen
like it definitely has like these like
core energy of our industry and I think
I was yeah 22 and I think it was just a
really good place to tell your take and
I remember because they were like you
know I just lied and the interview and
said that I did my own BD which I didn't
so it was just you know it was that kind
of you know that sort of supportive
environment and the chairman Paul he's
from where I live in Woking Surrey shout
out so it just felt very homey like
there's a lot of Surrey people here and
I was like oh perfect
right okay cool so just to set the scene
been here for six and a half years no
I'm sorry
oh Christ Silla so it's six and a half
years just to just to frame up so during
that period you've got what talks to me
just about the journey and well as in
like just job title and so they're used
from day one you're doing clients and
candidates yeah yeah so you can so in
then senior consultant then principal
consultant then senior principal
consoler and then practice lead then
business manager okay so what you do now
is it just beat like crime no so I
actually have a team okay they're
reporting to me okay in London and
there's people New York that I give jobs
to but I don't manage them directly so
they've got their own manager I think my
job might change like in the next few
months I'm not entirely sure but I might
focus more in the management piece but
right now how many people do you manage
for four okay and then how long for what
period of your time have you manage
people
is it only been in the last so as a
practice leads
I think it's our practice lead about
three years ago and then that's when
you're like your team leader you know
actually like you then you you're not
officially like you don't have a P&L
basically but you're you're involved in
there like day-to-day so you still
billing or not yeah I do still very well
by try July so okay just to help me
understand and so last three years you
man involved in management and you've
managed like small - yeah so basically
I'll give it a run down so we've saw you
go you get promoted to a certain level
and then you decide what route you want
to go down do you wanna be a manager do
you want to focus on being like a top
biller
yeah so they support you with whatever
go down it was I want you know for me I
kind of a dumb agreement for eight years
and I definitely get more fulfillment
from like helping and developing people
and they're doing deals and me being
involved in that sort of thing so it was
just a sort of natural yeah progression
and then the reason why my business
develop manager at the beginning this
year is you know I I'm again the kind of
man I am
I'm not the kind of lie you know
have you done that like I don't like
that style the way I like to manage
people is through helping them with
business developments I think that can
be the really hardest part of the job
you know doing it in for a long time
I've got a lot of relationships so it
just made sense naturally for me to pick
up jobs and I give them to my team you
feed your team okay cool so they spray
that down then I'm excited to talk about
this beady piece so let's let's just
like talk about the segments of your
career where until you go out to that
practice lead and that's where you
decided if you're gonna go down the
management root or top billary yeah so
before then what how did you do Billings
walnuts would be my best year 272
something okay decent it's alright yeah
sounds like so and that's always been
tech sales yeah that's all over done so
yeah okay so for ourselves right and
then how long and then the UK us piece
how and then up until the practically
piece was it just UK obviously so so
hasn't we actually have I think 10
offices now okay at the time we didn't
do anything we've got an office in New
York right we've got like 20 people new
look but I think about three years ago
we didn't have the reason why we opened
that office business and we realized
there was a massive opportunity so
naturally that's what are you doing
deals from the UK yeah in New York I was
placing salespeople we did a lot of work
with some of the big consultancies out
there so naturally there was loads of
business we had consultants going out
there all the time meeting clients and
placing people so they were like we need
to open office here there's a huge
opportunity okay so I then was doing
that and then from that I've just kind
of on and off always sort of place
people there then the peon hours are
different obviously because it would
just be crazy
that's why they said oh you can still do
a bit us alright sweet so early on its
salt then you'd never done BD before no
how the hell do you approach that
I think for me personally you know I I
appreciate that I am slightly annoying
and I use that to my advantage what you
mean in a in a good way so I think for
me personally it's all about putting
your personality across yeah and I think
that's how I've managed to be successful
in business development and that's how I
teach people my team's do business
development is you know BBB Emma put
yourself you know get them to know you
because ultimately it's a very
competitive environment they're gonna
get like 50 emails cause whatever it is
a day you need to somehow stand out from
the crowd
so how can someone start getting their
personality more so for me personally I
personally think it's easy with sales
like I you know I can't speak for
marketing I only know for sales and
sales is a very candidate led market
sorry that's it is that really no but so
if we get an absolute weapon of a can
they're you know they've done XY and
said they've closed x y&z deal
automatically you should be tapping up
all those hiring managers backing out
but I'm not talking there's nothing
worse than a recruiter that just does
like a blind Specter like oh you've got
this can they block yeah I literally
will meet someone so I'm gonna bet I
will meet someone sit down with them and
say where do you want to work like this
is about getting information from my
candidates where do you want to work
where's cool like tell me about the
market you know they're the ones selling
the product they're the ones working in
the space and they would say oh well you
know I've just want to deal against x
y&z or those guys are doing something
really cool with that kind of technology
and I'd be like cool and then I go on
LinkedIn and I would literally phone the
hiring manager and yes you know they get
a lot of approaches but if you generally
have something to say it's about
believing and what you're doing phone at
the home and you'll be like look I have
just met someone that you want to me you
will want to meet this person because
they're working it on your competitors
they're their top sales guy go do you
want to go for a coffee with them and
for me that's how like most of my
relationships have started like some of
my biggest accounts has
come from me harassing not harassing
people but you know in a nice way
and they kind of know who you are and
also it's about you know there's don't
don't do something if you've been told
to do it you don't believe in it like
you have to do something that you think
is worthwhile and for me it's about you
know if you've got an amazing Hannah day
and you do think they are amazing
then you shouldn't feel nervous to get
in touch with that hiring manager that
you know going to because you know what
you're doing is good because it's gonna
like benefit them
what kind of it what's your approach
that you just have no then you know well
you just said it's a candidate short
market so okay well okay and so then
okay you must have it's like what came
first the chicken or egg for me then and
this is another thing I said people on
my team is I just be honest with them
and say look I'm really new to the
market I know it probably it's probably
different more difficult now because
it's a lot more saturated people for we
can't be asked to spend the time of
recruiters but if you you know even if
you speak to a camera that you don't
think is that good not you know we do
think all candidates together yeah you
can still talk to them and understand
it's about market knowledge like for me
it's all about market in tower you know
I've got some clients and before from
you know when you see articles about
them receiving funding I know this
probably sounds so textbook but it does
actually work reaching out those people
be like oh my god you've just got this I
saw you in this it double bubble blah
you know I do I write passes which is
like blogs about certain articles I'll
send it to your hiring managers and be
like I just saw you posted about about
that well guess what I wrote an article
about it it kind of just shows that you
actually know what you're talking about
I feel like what you're doing there it's
like you're the reason why I asked you
that is because like so what I just
wanted to get your thoughts on with his
like and that's a lot I agree I had way
more success yeah when I'm see
ultimately you have a reason to call
them like that that's what it comes down
to the end the day you could sit there
two hours in your beedi power hour
whatever and have no reason to call yeah
that's when it's really difficult and
it's like this is [ __ ] and it's a whole
but what you're saying is then on that
point is worth its content or whatever
candidate and not so good can that they
have writ like you've got a reason I
think it's not I mean yeah I definitely
think you know we can call up any
company we want to and say hey can I
recruit for you they're gonna be like no
that's just not like why do they care
you know at the end the day you got to
respect their time they're busy people I
feel like if you go with them and you
know you don't even say can I recruit
for you it's like do you want to meet
this person it's a different
conversation and you know I'd find that
awkward I wouldn't call up someone and
go hi I see that you alright you know
kind on the candidate side then what how
how did you so obviously as you said you
had a year way you you build nearly 300
K that's decent so like obviously but
I'm assuming that when you start this
all you didn't have any clients had
access to your board yeah do you not I
mean it's like how did you start
building up the can does really well and
I think it's recommended is pick a
specialism like whatever it's gonna be
picking ish you know make yourself
really really good at one thing because
that for me personally is how people
have become super successful and it
worked for me and what did you nice down
so I so I recruit in software sales but
it specifically marketing technology so
when I joined there was like no
marketing technology vendors there was
like email marketing or e-commerce
platforms and I just networked with all
of those senior people and then now
honestly do you know them how did I
start so I would you know try and BD
some of the directors I'd also like
you've got like it's a niche within a
niche right so I'd get like a real
junior sales person like an inside sales
person that's you know not ready for a
big closing role but I'd take them to
market in like a different way as well
so it's just about I think just anytime
you find someone goods just utilizing
them as much yeah that is so difficult
to work a sales job and actually find
people that are really well suited it's
better to go right I've got this amazing
guy what can I do with him and actually
or woman and
she really understand it and I think if
you keep talking and if you are really
specialists you're gonna keep knocking
on the same doors eventually they're
gonna want to have a conversation I
think that's what worked for me
eventually people will just come back to
me and you know they would say yes or no
whatever but they would know who I am
and they'd know me and then you know yes
they then would have a job and they go
well Who am I gonna call like I'm gonna
go Emma because she's been harassed me
for the last six months in a nice way I
mean all you're saying is like you
stayed in touch yeah do you know I mean
like actually like be front of mind if
that's like okay okay I know you know I
know you're busy again but let me call
you back in yeah yeah but I think it's
again it's about having the knowledge
like I don't want anybody you know
recruiters do get a really bad rep and
it really irritates me I have it like
family barbecues and it's like we're
actually good at our job like I know a
lot about my clients I really invest
myself in them and you know what we're
doing is putting really good people with
really good companies there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that as long as you
know what you're talking about there's
nothing worse than somebody yeah you
know I wouldn't try and you know get him
get on board with like a tech company I
don't know anything about it and I'd be
the first person to be like just cuz I
know recruitment doesn't mean
necessarily I'd be able to feel what
would you say would you say you an
expert I'd say yeah in a nutshell you do
also touched on it there it's just out
of interest how did you get to the
expert status someone listening know
what I've done it for a year I feel
because you do you get more confident in
that but it's a lie so you said there
the like obviously niche down of so
you'd happy having conversation these
people much as possible but how did you
approach like really getting under the
bonnet of light your on your did you do
anything different besides like just
having conversations these people out
what else did you mean people as much as
possible guy is so cringe but going to
expose like it's not cringe like it's
honestly so so important like I one of
my biggest clients would they come from
they came from me trying to get in with
the
MD for like two years previous company
and they work with another agency I
won't say who okay she listening and he
was just like sorry
it's above my head so I can't work with
you two years right he got a job at this
new company he called me up out of the
blue and he just said I want to work
with you exclusively I've got the
freedom to do it and I did about you
know it's one of our biggest account and
has been flipped the last three years
cheers so you know and that was from me
you know he knew who I was and I think
it's about the most important thing is
putting your personality across as well
I find so you know even when you know if
we hire people that so if I've got
people on my team that are coming across
from other agencies and they're doing
like own email and it's that typical you
know structured like email that let's
face it
pretty much every recruiter in London is
sending and for me it's like of course
they're not gonna respond to you like
why would they do them I just think
you've got you've got to put your
personality of course in the way you
write you know in the way you kind of
write an email how you would talk you
know say why someone's goods not in a
bullet point format or that you've just
copied and pasted from their CV but
actually but with a bit of an emotion
with a bit of conviction like again they
were sales people as well we need to
sell to them why they should speak to us
so I think it's really important to do
that okay where and so will you talk
about that great a great story hoping
that absolutely love that I had the same
experience like but it's a bit bit man
but it's like a slightly different
experience so I started actually a bad
experience like this client is yeah so I
had this client who like I knew was like
just he had a this insurance break had
about four or five different jobs
there's loads of recriminations he's on
there and but they I'm just knew they
like charge less than we charged and his
mobile was on LinkedIn he just pull it
on there so he must get absolutely
peppered anyway yeah gave him a call
yeah and he finally called me back but
like you know and someone calls back and
in this light you get a partial my
colleague oh yeah and live sure in a BD
session and I didn't rely I just God
completely project I'll completely
crumble those like nada cry bars like
because like he call back and then I was
like someone said it like I don't think
I caught his name properly and I was
like who the [ __ ] said I don't know that
sort of thing anyway long story short he
call back
he got fries him and I was like I like
you again like who are you something
like absolutely crumbled just empty and
then he's like this is the worst call
ever largest don't call me cancer thing
so it doesn't happy ending so that
happens right but and then a lot of
stayed persistent like three months six
months I was like look I'm sorry we've
got off on a bad foot totally sorry I'm
sure yes I made a mistake that are there
and long story short
finally like broke the account yeah and
then like I made like four or five
placements and back-to-back so totally
get that I think people like
vulnerability that's what that says like
people like that's what makes you good
like you know I'm not talking about
yeah it's about showing you that you're
human like I've read this thing read
like literally listened to a podcast
this morning about it about how people
you know it's about having that human
interaction with people totally and it's
so important to show that you are a
person and that you're not just you know
no wonder recruiters get a bit of a bad
rep when you're being told or you are
spec'ing out people to like 50 hiring
managers and you've got this guy or
whatever you know they get so many of
those emails like you know when you've
got friends that go internal and they
show you the emails and you're like no
wonder people think we are [ __ ] some of
us are [ __ ] and I think it's just about
being better what usually so nether in
that story which is what I want to do to
talk a bit about is like that you had to
remain persistent like that I mean
that's hard yeah so how have you
cultivated like
resilience basically like how have you
gone about that I don't I like obviously
crying a lot not anything I don't know
really like I think I've been really
lucky to work in a business that is very
very supportive I've never feared for my
job if things haven't gone my way and
it's near
and
not been I've not always done really
well like some months your blank you
know you might even black for two months
and it's the worst feeling when you're
trying so hard like everyone knows the
phrase is you know recruitment is
champagne and or raised blades no no you
either literally celebrating or you want
to kill yourself yeah so how do you do
anything is how you get free that you
know I'm 28 now 30 next year woohoo wait
you're 28 it doesn't mean you're Fae
next year yeah it does
29 December oh sorry I think it's like
an age thing um I think it's about
seeing the bigger picture like it is
honestly again really cringey to say but
I just actually love doing recruitment I
love recruitment so I'm not I think
sometimes it's difficult to motivate
people if maybe you know people come
into recruitment and they want to leave
after six months a year they want to go
into cells would do whatever you can't
make people want to stay and do it yeah
but if you do want to stay into it I
think that end goal kind of keeps you in
it because they're all gonna be good
times there are gonna be bad times like
you know James my old manager is in New
York now he used to say like you need to
be as emotionless as possible like you
need to take out a motion from the
situations because you shouldn't really
necessarily celebrate when things are
going really well and you shouldn't
really hate it when things are going bad
you've just got to kind of remain one
level of calmness have you managed that
then have you done terribly doing that
much better now my thinking about the
last two years probably so maybe since I
turned 26 I think you're talking about
aged way too much man no no I do I'm
just trying it's like the timeline in my
head
I think for the last two years I've like
stabled out like before that
just I think you've got to look after
your own mental health like he's gonna
make it a priority you've got mental
have the priority you've got you know
everyone in recruitment likes to drink
but really sickly don't go out in the
way you can drink cuz it's just not
gonna have you do they like trust me no
I honestly I don't think I should I'm
pretty sure I didn't do like a day of
like recruitment hungover but I didn't I
didn't work in London july i worked in
heresy if and like it's just like
farmland base today oh nice that's
probably the dream now honestly I had so
I had to like drive an hour to work oh
wow do you know I mean so either it's a
lot I couldn't think of it anything
worth and doing recruitment hangover I
don't know I did you know I look back at
myself and I'm right I think that's just
being young and I think most young you
start doing them dislike how do you
start looking after your mental health
for anything that you start to do
different so always make sure you go to
the gym always make sure that you get
sleep sleep yes Liam don't drink try and
plan things like you know it's kind of
like a you know sort of grand mal thing
to say but like get into a routine
yeah and stick to the routine and just
prioritize what you do yourself like so
a really good like I've got life coach
just really she's not amazing because I
think everything all sort of links
together if you're happy in outside
we're definitely happy inside of work
you're gonna be happy you're gonna be
successful of course
so I love you have a life coach for I
think about three months now it's quite
a new thing or not
yeah so they do it so I think right
management or so I so basically what
you're saying is in the last two years
you've got much better it's a maturity
thing as well that's fair it's a lot
ultimately what you send there you just
got better at having a bit of
perspective in those my
not letting someone else's emotion know
what it is like my sister works in like
mental health and she honestly has to
deal with some of the most horrible
circumstances I in her day-to-day job
and she was actually one of the people
that put into perspective because I had
a person that cancelled an interview
like final interview and it meant I
wouldn't have got my bonus and there we
get like a five grand bonus four and a
half grand and it meant I've missed my
bonus and I literally like lost my share
I was so annoyed she came home from work
and I was telling me this story about
you know whatever happened in this
mental ward weren't going to details and
she's literally paid like absolutely
pittance and I just really got some
perspective about like Emma stop moaning
about feeling so true it's just so silly
if someone cancels interview just
rearrange it or find another candidate
like we're not we're not doctors here
we're not saving lives I think it's
about having perspective on what we do
I'm going to know what do the best job
that you can do but also don't take it
home with you and don't let it like
Russell you keep it up and I even though
you know respect is big yeah like
meditation however that oh yeah
meditation is really good
I do meditate but not often I tried to
like meditate more phezzan that just
helped me be able to like take a step
back in those moments because I've
struggled that early on okay so how come
you how come you pit the management rig
then what did you always want to know
you want to do that or I don't know I I
think for me I like coaching people I
really like seeing people do well
because of stuff that I've like
specifically done to help them yeah and
it just gives me more fulfillment like
I'm not money motivated I like money how
was i I must have been I I was to like
some degree but then I think it comes a
point where you know you can earn loads
of money but you're not feeling
fulfilled and what you're doing in day
you can just keep placing people and
like woohoo like ring the bell but it's
not that exciting do you remember
getting your biggest ever paycheck yeah
having you do well I was gonna say I get
a lot of big do you remember I remember
getting my first bonus okay that was
that was actually more of a defining
moment for me I got my first bonus I got
my first big paycheck and yeah I went
and bought a Prada handbag come on I
know how cliche right I think I must
have been about 23 years old so the
reason why I asked you that is like how
did you feel so happy made in life
really yeah I felt the opposite oh my
god it's because of your appointment you
said there like you said you just send
them like yeah you can get this money
but if you don't feel fulfilled I'm just
like so look to my bank and I was like I
hope feeling a fin lot obviously I was
happy I've definitely lost a lot of
perspective on money and my dad would
say that like I have no prospects for my
money because the amount of money that
we earn for doing not like obviously we
do a lot but you know I think you kind
of think you know it is a lot of money
and we are really really fortunate
situations to be in to work in this
career because it's obviously extremely
lucrative but how have you got better
managing your money than mate because
that's definitely like that's that's an
interesting thing as you said yeah it's
actually come up I think once or twice
before s like 23 year old Korea and in
six figures whatever the [ __ ] sound that
person have you better of that again
also you know what I think I just had to
grow up mortgage I've got a cat you know
he's not gonna feed himself mine then
would you do anything different like
with like would you advise me to that 24
year old self I do you know what you
know I'm a person that says don't have a
great I don't know if I necessarily you
know I think you need to go through
things yeah I wouldn't necessarily be
you know you and me said like do not
cats what you do that bill I out of
interest lines you think you'd sort of
give that person an advice but no
because you know what it was fun laughs
like I look back and I'm like no war i
when
an amazing trip sigh I did so much fun
stuff I had such a fun life yeah and now
you know I'm kind of at the age from
like no war I've done all that it's like
giving me really good experiences and
now I'm just you know I want to you know
yeah priorities to change I think that's
just about growing up yeah and I
wouldn't say necessarily you know maybe
don't do out doing that because then
what like fennel you're just gonna have
a board like I think those are kind of
what your twenties are for I did you
know your early 20s are for just ya know
so just like learning who you are as a
person
yes as I said like yeah I mean it's when
you owning that type of cash and it's
like well okay well known as tell me how
to manage my money before I do you know
I mean you could make some bad mistakes
with money I know yeah so so how did you
transition to into management in like
did you like mentor people for what we
call practice leave which is essentially
like a team lead role okay just one
person no I think it was managing three
and do you so you went from not manage
than anyone
well no actually so like they do it kind
of gradually so if you start saying you
want to go down management route you
know that you might get a resources so I
think I originally started one one girl
and she was like my resource just sort
of coaching her yeah yeah doing a like
sitting high up in the morning some what
you're gonna do which is so on and then
just gradually we're getting like bigger
and bigger and then you get promoted to
that role okay some learnings that
you've experienced in your management
career mate talk to me that was you a
good manager from quite after I think
okay so I think I don't I think it's
about being don't don't be a manager
that someone else don't try managing the
way that someone else tells you to
manage okay do you know what I mean like
there's not a cookie cutter way to
management that's my opinion if you've
got certain personality traits you
should kind of go with your gut instinct
and go well I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
do that rather than try and you know if
your manager manages you in a certain
way it doesn't mean that necessarily
you're gonna be like that I don't know
if I'm making
but so for me I think with me I tried a
lot to do things I okay well I've got to
do this because someone's told me to do
in your own you've got to do that but I
think it's it takes time to have
confidence in your own voice and
actually say well this is how I think
I'm gonna go over my gut feeling here I
think it's about kind of trusting
yourself more so that would be one thing
is kind of trust in yourself to make
make a good decision do you have anyone
solve that you was learning from more
like so my manager was Gareth
so he's an amazing amazing manager here
and he's got a different team now yeah
so he was sort of like coaching me but
me and him like personality wise I like
chalk and cheese so different but he is
an amazing manager and it was just like
you know it we're just sort of different
in terms of like yeah how you might
deliver a leave of staff so that's what
some of the cool things that really
helped them did you'd like I have like
some really good processes or did ya say
he yes so well we have I'm just trying
to feedback now so we what just in terms
of like just like so how you got so
someone that's come up quite a long is
people who want to move into manage so
it might be someone that isn't
management right now might be struggling
or a finger map management or whatever
and where you've obviously in obviously
you'll be managing off like three years
you might have lights and things that
you've just done for a while now what
you know just set you up the best way to
manage your people so a real common
thing and is quite a few people said
that when they said when they said to
their team like right
so if unless it's like life or death you
can grab you and like speak to me oh my
god now or basically I trust you like
between 12:00 and 1:00 like that's when
you can book and time with me and speak
to me whatever okay I think again
everyone's different yes so I'm not
gonna say how I am like is my ways the
right way but for me I just think you
need to be there for your team like a
million zillion percent like I'm very
much I'm not a micromanager I don't give
a [ __ ] about you know how many CV sends
you say
how many you know what you've done I
don't even really look at that kind of
stuff for me it's all about are you
doing the best work you can do and also
like trying to coach people through
making the best decisions like if I hear
someone on the phone or if I can see
something they're doing oh my god let me
help you with this let me do this like
I'll go on the phone you listening that
kind of thing
and I think you've just always gotta
peers like I would never say or don't
talk to me between these hours right
they can talk to me whenever they want
and at the end of the day I kind of I
think in has a recruitment manager you
do kind of have to be a bit of I could
cancer at the same time as well like the
amount of times I've cried so my former
managers like they probably should have
charged me for like therapy services I
think you've got to be that person like
you you know recruitment is hard it's so
up and down ultimately some things we do
are completely out of our control
and it's like someone new it can be so
disheartening like I've got a girl on my
team at the moment she's absolutely
amazing she's been with us for about
three months and she's had the shittiest
couple of weeks like through no for her
own and you know that for me as a
manager is difficult to see because
she's working really really hard so it's
like just trying to support her and be
like you know what this will happen for
you like you're doing everything right
like this will all make sense just keep
doing the right thing so that's what my
mother did to me yeah yeah okay how dis
American peas come about what did it
happen quite naturally of your desk that
you ended up
sorry placements in America so a lot of
the companies we work for SAS businesses
that are either US companies coming over
to Europe or European SAS businesses and
naturally they would be like do you have
to be from the US so a lot of the
clients I used to work for were already
US companies I think I had a client that
basically was a UK based company and
they said oh do you have any one in New
York cuz we're gonna expand to New York
and I was like oh I'll do it and that's
basically how it came about yeah I was
yeah sure of like I'll give it a go and
then how have you how have you found so
I've had a couple of people now the
built their American part of their desk
like a year maybe year and a half before
they went over or sometimes shorter and
went over there
typically people who said and people
will weigh more assets to pick up 500%
really how what's been your experience
in the UK so we like cover the whole of
Europe so I think each different country
has their own sort of traits like
Germany is so hard in my opinion like no
one wants to talk to you there were very
loyal to their employers the u.s. is
just really like people don't have this
in sales I'm talking specifically no we
don't have the same perception like here
it's like we then they need to say three
years three years three years in the
u.s. it's like they don't care about
that they are literally just chasing for
the best opportunity so then how they
pick up the phone even if they've been
there coming for a week and hiring
managers who aren't the same they don't
say well this person has to be there
three years three year three years
because no one has been so they're just
way more open to a conversation even if
they're not interested they recommend
people like I just feel like they're
just
I think the recruitments are not more
respected in the US House it helped it
just helps a lot because you can have
conversations with people I think that's
half the battle like we're all trying to
speak to people you can't really
convince them to go for an interview if
you can't even speak to them and you
know I think that's the beauty of when
you were the US market they will pick up
the phone to you and have a chat with
you it's a conversation can you make
more money in America I do you know what
I've done like a mixture so I've done a
mixture of you can US but like you know
I think it was like last year I had to
do like a few highs in the US and I did
like three of them and then they all
started like the next month and it was
absolutely sweet but the term did like
turns everyone saying like yeah
America's favorite and I mean I don't
know maybe they're just really good
recruiters I personally haven't worked
at very person what style you like
twenty to twenty-five really yeah just
basically the same as the UK but
our American team like the guys in the
u.s. do amazingly like they're really
really good recruiters name yeah no
disinterested because like I'm sure
you've seen the whole everything's in
like America like yeah and loads of fees
you can but it's all like you know it's
really it's expensive to live in America
as well like the cost of living in New
York is really super high so you know I
personally think it's all relative you
spent how much time you spent in New
York quite a lot of time like July if
someone's thinking about moving to New
York to recruit what the hell should
they be thinking about so I actually I
I've dinner if you ever met him
again with Afghans all the details you
know it's on Cotterell yeah so let's
give you context I live with Tom he's
actually been on the podcast but anyway
anyway anyway in a nutshell
don't ask go into details but like yes
that's what I mean so like obviously
to be fair like everyone can be a trap
like I said attracted to London and I
definitely was but I've never been to
New York I'm definitely go in knew I
didn't have a cat and a boyfriend I've
moved to New York really I think it's
like yeah like it's just got an amazing
you just I love the aura of New York
when you go there it's like it's a great
thing but I also think me quite a lonely
place that's what I mean yeah yeah I
think it is quite a lonely place like me
personally I need my personal space now
I've lived alone for a very long time I
would never ever want to have share with
anybody that is not my idea of Hell so
um you know if it was to move that I
wouldn't possibly be out I don't think
I'd be able to in a solid they're not
Brooklyn or something for my own place
you'd probably have to like share with
someone yeah if I be like just from your
experience being there and stuff like
that like fun recruiter right now I love
free for his experience and someone's
hit me on alert yeah there's an
opportunity so New York I was saying
earlier but what should I actually think
about because like the retro excellent
sent me that you can unfocus empathise
talk to me about the actual reality
living that I don't know like the ins
and outs of things but you definitely
have taken into consideration living
course you definitely to take in
situation the different tax
is don't know what it is but I think
it's like 40% I don't know don't hold me
to that might make that up mother just
yeah I mean I I think gopher like if
you're in that position and you want to
do something I think New York's an
amazing place I would definitely say
yeah not just interested because I did a
podcast of something that also went to
New York and and he just found that like
obviously but people typically in New
York they're like set up there they've
got their friendship groups and stuff on
that so it can actually be quite it can
be quite a bit of a challenge we've
relocated a lot of people I think
obviously if you're going to business
where there's like a 20 foot all over me
there your [ __ ] people and like
that's that's obviously really useful
yeah but no I totally get that like 100
percent all right so when I moved up to
London there's just minimum a and I've
said it a few times like it's just
something a weird feeling when you're
surrounded by people every day come into
work but then you get home and you just
feel like she likes weird and like in
New York where yeah it's even more
busier fuel and of all these people
you're gonna move anyway you gotta throw
yourself into it put yourself out there
yeah yeah fair enough mate so as we
finish may be finished in already was
gonna say what I'd love to get your
thoughts on before we finish two things
so obviously we spoke quite a bit about
business development early on and
throughout but now you managing people
when like I'll see you have a focus on
BD know what were like the common
mistakes that you see people will do or
like common things that you see people
make the sort of you you see that
prevents them from having more success
would be the end stuff for us okay so
number one is stand out from the crowd
do not do what all your colleagues are
doing like if you're gonna send someone
email make it about you don't be don't
be scared to like let your personality
shine through in an email don't you know
do the standard thing actually show who
you are get them to know like the real
person that's super important why do
know okay
best of all like I didn't like just out
of interesting video well I was seen the
people I interview or drove with it's
like you can send a video and emails
like because I've done and it worked on
so just actually don't just do the point
in right if you look at the people and
my teams that LinkedIn we any post that
we do it's like put you across like if
you're recruiting for a company put it
in your day to day life talk about how
it affects you you wouldn't put yourself
across yeah okay secondly is don't just
try one Avenue lotto I've emailed them
like who cares you've emailed them have
you added them on LinkedIn you know we
send these email projects now and it's
like oh they've not replied to me yeah
have you actually added them because
then you cannot see when they're online
you can like send them a little message
them you know so like don't don't get
complacent with are now done what's that
like story when it's like if you can't
go round it go under it if you can't get
hold of someone from one way like try
the other way the other way keep going
ultimately you should make a list of top
10 accounts that you were like those are
the accounts that I'm gonna break no
matter what happens those the accounts
I'm gonna work with and you should put
them on a pedestal and you should do
everything you can to get into those
accounts and if you're good enough and
you know what you're talking about
like why wouldn't they want to of you
okay unless they work and we saw already
then they definitely want a mage I guess
is that is that you know keeping then
get your personality across yes email
way be persistent and and you know do
other ways don't just do what everyone
else is talking about your ways mate
come on
so five months out 10 account I go to
the top straightaway so go to like sea
level go to CEO you know if you you know
you're looking to like get into a
software business go straight to the top
message them then go down a level then
go down a level like ads people never
add a charge okay just quickly so
alright so I'm not some what's in the
column yeah I'm gonna go straight at the
top yeah what my dentists trying to get
how am i doing okay I'm very open about
so if you got my link
like I say the companies we work with
talk about relevant stuff to them if
there are you know email marketing
platform say these are all the other
email marketing platforms that I recruit
for these are all the roles I've placed
are you interested
talk to me like it's all about relevance
okay they get a lot of emails so from
different recruiting or calling them at
this stage just straight email I would
just do an email and I'd you know I
think and I know there's like so much
thing about all cold cooling is not dead
cold cooling is dead I don't know if
it's dead or not I'm not here to judge
but for me personally I wouldn't want to
do a cold call like I would email them
add them on LinkedIn and kind of go down
that approach you know if I really
wanted to get into them after doing a
few times I I literally will keep
sending messages not like hello hello
like [ __ ] messages but try and make it
you know you don't want to keep annoying
someone then maybe you could call them
because you know I told you I'm really I
think cooling someone like you know
we've all been cold cool by retro acts
our desk and it's like
they feel awkward calling you you can
tell they're no so why are you calling
me and that's the same thing for people
that were calling as well I yes I don't
know but there are probably a lot of
recruiters out there that do cocoa and
they like standby it so I think it's
just whatever works for the start at all
yeah then work your way down I'm going
to do that just because they obviously
the better if you have someone bought in
at the top then they have more decision
exactly and I think you should be able
to do yeah like you should go to the top
of their business they're the ones that
are gonna know they're the ones that
more power
alright and then one other actually just
on the BD topic you do vents
yeah do I'm doing event next week how
hug how long how long we've done events
for this is actually my first event sort
of done events for like years but this
is my first personal first event why why
did you decide to start an event because
you know what it was I think it's just
one of those things you know when you do
like a little business plan every
quarter and you say what you want to do
what you want to achieve I've been
saying for so long I want to do an event
or do an event and it's just like you
know what just [ __ ] do it actually
just do it and it was a good time
because it's come at the end of the year
we've got a few different events
at the same time and I just said look I
want to get this done I want to do it
and yeah so it's the reason why I was
curious about it because I had so I did
a podcast with a chap called Kyle who he
again he's like all about smashing the
phones and all that and it's still very
much believed that however like he was
really struggling to get through
switchboard all the normal stuff right
and then he decided to start an event
series and the world suddenly had the
c-level high-level people going yeah
that's how you're cool yeah I'll speech
the man the vendors you know talking
about have you found that if you went or
did you rely on your existing network to
try and get people to get involved well
i i've actually got people in the pack
like the people on the panel with people
that we recruit for but then also i had
i did contact people i don't recruit for
that i just because it's about women in
sales has like a lack of diversity so i
just reached out to some women that I
knew who I had never recruited for but I
like we rated them yeah so whether
they're not on the panel but they came
back to me and it was like a good way to
have a conversation
all of a sudden yeah again it's like I
think they respect you in a different
way like I it does really kind of grind
my gears how rougarou's do have a really
bad rep and it's like we're not bad like
we're smart people we know what we're
talking about and I think when you do an
event or if you do like a blog you're
actually showcasing that you do know
what you're talking about and you're not
just like some some London like one of
the worldís yeah so how do you think you
should mention it a few times how do you
think this how do you think this replica
women can change me we in place in there
right now me just do a good job do the
right thing do the right thing like that
is what it comes down to do the right
thing if you get a job and you can't
find anyone tell the client you can't
find anyone in stage no war I know that
you know Tom down the road recruits to
that area why don't you contact them
like I've actually had recommendations
from other recruiters I've been past
candidates from other recruiter
we do that too it's like I can't place
you but speak to that area like go back
to people you know give them feedback
and it's that you know I think if
everyone starts doing that at the end of
the day the good ones probably do that
anyway and that's why they're good and
that's why they're always going to have
candidates and clients are going to use
them for the rest of you [ __ ] get
your [ __ ] together oh yeah I totally get
it I think I don't know I think those
what there's there's so many good
recruiters out there there's so many
goodies out there solo as we finish mate
mmm
before I do ask you the final question
what you're excited about
obviously your event I think this is
gonna go out before the event happen
like off the event happens me anyway
excited about me what's going on in your
world I'm going to Thailand in December
for months oh wow I'm going off grid
guys I'm doing that I'm traveling more
okay but the missus nice but it's the
first time I'm doing that as well how do
you feel about it I'm really excited
like when you say off the grid what
we're talking why are you like putting
out of office on the whole time off grid
LA I'm the kind of person that will
obviously you know my clients you know
they gonna message me but I think it's a
good time to do because Christmas really
sickening agree more no one cares anyway
yeah I think it was first let me do know
I never like going away for like a long
period of time
yeah like I'm really I'm really
interesting yeah anything else you were
cream for you team then Thailand for a
month in December nice May it's pretty
much been on an interesting journey mate
thanks last question oh if you could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there they take on your advice ed
listen that implements it tomorrow could
be a phrase a sentence what would Emma
say to the mate good question
what comes to mind I think it's you know
we've already touched me but I do think
it comes down to actually I was gonna
say do the right thing but actually I'm
gonna say cool strive for the best fine
for the best
like if someone says to you if you've
got a job and they want somebody from
not a competitor I get someone from
their competitor like don't send them
free TVs from free people that aren't
their competitors like wait until you've
got the best and do what you can to get
the best like always strive for the best
and everything you're doing boom
they think you might enjoy that Thanks